Pixar brings us joy sadness anger
disgust and fear in the 15th animated
feature which takes us inside the mind
of eleven-year-old Riley I'm Jan and
this is 25 things you probably didn't
know about inside out the basic design
of each of the movies 5 emotions was
inspired by particular shape joy is
based on a star sadness an upside-down
teardrop fear on a nerve anger on a
firebreak and disgust on broccoli though
director Pete docter says he actually
loves broccoli when they were animating
joy the filmmakers channeled a mix of
Audrey Hepburn Amelie star Audrey toeto
and Bugs Bunny and the way joy moves is
inspired by Jim nap for sadness the
animators took cues from characters such
as Wednesday Addams from The Addams
Family and Debbie Downer from Saturday
Night Live while for disgust they were
inspired by parks and recs April Ludgate
and Veruca Salt from Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory and for fear they
referenced comedic actor Don Knotts and
mr. bean when it came to anger even in
their early pictures the filmmakers had
in mind comedian Lewis Black who
actually provides the voice for anger in
the final movie Catelyn Diaz who plays
eleven-year-old Riley was originally
just hired to record a temporary voice
track so the filmmakers could present
their storyboard ideas but they loved
her performance so much that they cast
her in the final movie not only was the
story of inside out inspired by director
Pete doctor's experience of his daughter
Allie growing up but according to
character art director Albert Lozano
Riley even looks like Ellie
Owen by the way le docteur was also the
voice of young Ellie in Pixar's movie
earth remember the scenes where Riley
makes it quite clear she's not a fan of
a particular green vegetable well in
Japan kids generally like broccoli so
the filmmakers reanimated those scenes
and replaced broccoli with green peppers
and while North American audience is
watching inside out see Riley's dad
daydreaming about ice hockey during
dinner in other places such as the UK
ice hockey was replaced with soccer
Riley's imaginary friend Bing bong was
partly inspired by peek doctors own
imaginary friends from childhood a car
driving little elephant called Norman
for Bing bong the animation team also
channels comic actors Oliver Hardy
Jackie Gleason and John Candy but the
film makers it was essential to give
both the human world and the world
inside Riley's mind a distinct look so
audiences could immediately tell the
difference between them so the artists
look to nineteen fifties Broadway
musicals for the bright saturated colors
of the mind world and to give the human
world a more real feel there's more of a
handheld or Steadicam look to come up
with the design of the long-term memory
storage area the filmmakers researched
various manufacturing facilities they
took a tour of the Jelly Belly Candy
factory where they're inspired by the
way the colors moved through the tubes
in their automated packaging machinery
and they also visited an egg processing
plant to get ideas for how delicate
objects like memories could be moved
from one place to another Pete docter
has described dream productions the
place where Riley's dreams and
nightmares are created as a mixture of
Saturday Night Live and the magic of
Hollywood in fact is inspiration for the
movie doctors spent a week observing
behind the scenes of Saturday Night Live
as a guest of Bill Hader who plays the
voice of fear in inside hours director
Pete docter and producer Jonas Rivera of
both massive fans of Disneyland so when
it came to creating the right look for
Imaginationland in Riley's mind world
theme parks were the biggest inspiration
when they were designing the
subconscious inside outs artists drew
heavily on classic horror movies
especially for their theatrical lighting
to develop the look of the train of
thought which delivers daydreams and
ideas in the mind world the filmmakers
visited a train museum and also
consultive john lasseter who's not only
chief creative officer at Walt Disney
and Pixar Animation Studios who's also a
lifelong train enthusiast just like
Riley Pete docter grew up in Minnesota
and later moved to the Bay Area though
according to him in inside out
moving is more of a metaphor for growing
up the address of Riley's home in San
Francisco is 21 Royal Street which just
happens to be the name of a new private
dining venue at Disneyland
and is a nod to the Walt Disney Family
museum the filmmakers located Riley's
hockey rink in the same place the museum
is located in San Francisco when
composer Michael Giacchino
first discussed the movie score at a
construction site where Pete docter was
building a house little did he know the
location of that meeting would influence
the movies music but some pieces of
metal that Jackie no son found to the
site produced such a nice sound that
jikido gave them to the percussion
section to play with little metal songs
you can hear them in the first musical
cue just after the memory ball comes
down to make sure they really understood
how the mind works and also have preteen
might deal with traumatic events inside
outs filmmakers worked with scientists
neurologists and psychologists and de
Klerk helped the Hughes professor of
psychology at the University of
California Berkeley helped them choose
which emotions to feature in the film
out of the more than 20 emotions that
are recognized by psychologists now
which is your favorite character in
inside out and why and which is your
favorite Pixar movie tell me in the
comments below so guys if you liked this
video I'd really appreciate you sharing
it and if you'd like to see more videos
like this do please subscribe I'm going
to be making an Easter eggs video for
inside out and I'll add a link to that
here when it's ready and I've also got a
review of the Hunger Games Mockingjay
part 2 on the way thanks for watching
and see you next time you B guy a movie
lovers
you